so this is Sal Khan founder of the Khan
Academy and this is a very exciting
Skype call that we're on I'm with Ben
Hedrick who's the lead for AP Calculus
what do you do at the College Board
really anything with AP Calculus NAEYC
ap statistics just something that I have
a little bit of control over so for
example freaky calculus anything with
the curriculum anything with the
assessment is something that I work with
and I'm sure that you're as excited as I
am and and you know several hundred
thousands of students are around the
country for the AP exams that are coming
up in roughly a little less a little
less than a week and I thought a fun
place to start would be when you guys
write the test what are you trying to
assess what's kind of the the spirit of
the questions both on the
multiple-choice and the free response
section so what we're looking for from
students is evidence of good conceptual
understanding and calculus now we have
some things that are going to test
procedures but really we want students
to understand what's going on with the
calculus rather than just calculating
things or putting numbers on paper a lot
of thinking questions a lot of insight
to make sure that whatever good calculus
those students have learned in their
courses we're assessing it on the AP
exam and you know I've done a bunch of
example problems for for the AP exam and
yeah my sense of it is you sometimes
will do some of the the minutia work or
you'll give the formula and you're
really trying to understand whether
students understand the essence of what
an integral is or the essence of you
know derivative is a rate of change or
the slope of a tangent line so if you
were preparing for this exam if you were
these students what would you suggest to
them you know obviously we have a little
less than a week for this current test
so what advice would you have for those
students and then just generally as
students go through the year what should
they think about it yeah the advice I
would give is depending on how much time
students how to prepare so the advice
that I give at the beginning of the year
is different from the advice that I get
now several days before the exam getting
ready for it first relax you know
this is a calculus exam we're not going
to be throwing anything at you from left
field
it's calculus you need to know limits
you need to know derivatives you need to
know integrals in term
of preparation make sure you're taking
the time to review the basics every
question that they see is going to hit
one of those big topics so make sure you
know your derivative rules make sure you
know your integral rules take a look at
the old exams and see how we're asking
questions and you look at the pattern
instances that we're always asking about
understanding what a derivative means
understanding integration of the idea of
accumulation there are no secrets on the
exam so really stick with what we've
done make sure that you're thinking of
ways to apply your good knowledge and
just review your basics in my experience
with the exam is there's a lot of as you
just said the really the mainstream
media topics you know a chain rule
fundamental theorem or theorems of
calculus things like that what's your
sense of the the more what I would
consider maybe a little bit more than
minutiae is some of the more special
case derivatives or special case
integrals you know arctangent debate how
much does that play into the exam you
know I think so you've actually answered
your own question and asking that is it
is the minutia so really at this point
in time if you're getting ready for the
exam spending time on the minutia is not
where you're going to be best served
with your time should be hitting the
major things and you said Arendt the
beginning chain rule in any kind of
question we do with derivatives you know
if you're doing in Max's or mins if you
doing tangent lines if you're doing a
related rates problem they're all
derivatives derivatives derivatives and
if you're having trouble with a chain
rule it doesn't matter how much my new
sheet you spend your time with the chain
rule is going to come up so I would say
don't sweat the minutia there might be
something on the exam that you haven't
reviewed as much as you want to but it's
going to be one single solitary question
basic derivatives are going to form the
basis for all those problems so that's
where your time is best about yeah I
definitely get that sense especially you
know how do you interpret the first
second you know derivatives concavity
things like that those seem to show up a
lot but once again that's the D that's a
conceptual idea of derivatives and on
the integration side I've been doing a
bunch of the free response it just seems
like I mean you know what happens if you
swap the bounds of integration or if you
add integrals if they so a lot of the
properties and the conceptual
understanding would an integral
is but you know not necessarily like the
fancy tricks at least at this point if
you're studying absolute there's there's
nothing that we go after the fancy
tricks we're not trying to ask your
questions or playing gotcha moments on
it it's really assessment of calculus
and for the students who have been going
through these great courses all year
this is a wonderful opportunity to show
us everything that you know and get a
really great score on the exam and and
what about calculator I mean I was doing
some of the free response that first
part of the free response to knowing
your calculator well helps oh absolutely
the the calculator is a tool and like
any tool you want to make sure that
you're applying it appropriately and
strategically which sometimes means
using your calculator and using it well
incorrectly but other times not using
your calculator I mean even the free
response section where the calculator is
being used we expect students to show
their work if you're taking an integral
we want to see that you've actually
taken that integral now the calculator
will do the work of it we want to see
the notation that says this is the
integral you calculated and this is the
answer you obtained and then do whatever
you will with that answer as required by
the question but good communication
through writing even on the calculator
sections necessary and for students
taking the the BC exam above and beyond
the the core differentiation integration
you know a lot of what you learn about
parametric equations is actually just an
extension of what you learn in
differentiation integration but probably
some of the the convergence tests are
something to become pretty familiar with
that would be correct yes and in terms
of grading of the exam you know some
people it to get a to get a five or a
high my understanding is you don't need
to answer absolutely every question
perfectly well like any test if you want
to date it well you don't have to have
perfection on it and this you know this
is a test where students are coming in
and it's a three-hour time thethe little
over three hour time test and you know
you can do a lot of really good work in
earn I pretty easily so I wouldn't I
wouldn't tell anyone to go in there
worrying about trying to figure out what
magical numbers they need to get in
order to get a perfect score on the test
or to get a five on the tester whatever
it is they're going for
just go in like you would on any test do
your best on every question get every
point that you can and hopefully it'll
work out fine for you what advice would
you have for students especially on the
free response where there's multiple
sections and if you know in part a they
say well that that's I don't I don't get
with that what what you know should they
skip to the next what should they do I
actually have very very common base on
that one is that's to make sure that
students are trying every part of every
response question one of the
misconceptions students have is exactly
what you said if you hit Part A and
you're freaking out a little bit because
you don't know what Part A is about
that's okay move on to Part B there are
some questions where the answer for Part
B depends on Part A but for the majority
of the questions they're separate pieces
so Part A Part B Part C if there's a
Part D they may all be asking very
different things
and if you have probably even with Part
C that doesn't mean you know the
question gets progressively more
difficult give Part D a try
and a lot of the things that we do get
points for our good solid calculus work
so if you can set up a problem maybe you
don't have time to finish it maybe you
make some mistakes along the way the
answer point is only one little point
out of enough iron there are other
points for the setup and the conceptual
understanding of the problem and a lot
of students have good conceptual
understanding that they could set up
pick up a point here and have a point
there but they panic a little bit and
they move on to another question and
never come back and that's okay if you
want to move on to another question but
absolutely I would say if you're having
trouble with Part A that's alright
take a look at Part B and one thing that
I've observed is a lot of these
questions at first when you look I'm
like oh wow this looks like some really
you know super deep thing but it really
is some core basic calculus ideas and
that if you're on the right track it's
actually quite simple so if you know
would you say it's fair if a student
finds themselves doing a very hairy
calculation that they might question
whether they need to go beyond might
they should question what they're doing
if if you've done something where you
feel like you need to prove a new
calculus theorem in order to answer it
something has gone terribly terribly
wrong and also if you feel like you need
to bring in some sort of mathematics
you've never seen before in calculus I
mean I as much as I hate to say it you
know this is
oculus is limits its derivatives its
integrals even though there's a lot of
wealth in that one if you're doing
something beyond that probably something
is going wrong yeah yeah well thanks I
think
you know thousands of AP students are
going to really appreciate that any
other kind of parting words for the
company test you know it's the the same
thing that I used to tell my students
when I was teaching AP calculus this is
just another test and the beauty of AP
is the teachers have been prepping their
students since the beginning of the year
it's one of the few tests where everyone
knows what's coming so when you sit down
and you've got free response questions
you've got multiple choice questions you
know there really shouldn't be any
surprises
this is the stuff they've seen all year
they know what to do take a moment take
a breath take a look at the problem get
all the points that you can show us that
good councils awesome and I'll throw in
a plug we have tons of resources for the
students as well and we're going to have
our office hours on on Monday so super
exciting thanks a bunch of ed know
thanks for having me